coming back home comforts of your own
bed being able to do
the often sputtered a bit on the trip
Janice the bus stop mean by barely first
to pointless yeah just see honest come
out first possession execute a state on
the floor a little flat but it was a
good idea
Matthews going to Bledsoe be honest
after rims 3 back foot back 3 to 6 in
less than 5 minutes at the garden to
take a timeout 8 to 0
you got to take a timeout honest a
moment ago he goes right back to the rim
it has 6 points this Julius Randle Cole
but they have got some Robinson just
said
si vous plait let's watch anis we're
talking Paris range shots that's not
what Mike Miller was--that's wives at
home that these guys move the ball get a
good look 14 points Megan will be
running Sora in this quarter to talk
Paris really building that them to hell
last season to come out of his game
finds wounds double team really know
where to go home did by Dick's Robinson
doing a good job forcing them left
well he's still able to eat loot him get
the hoop this the most upset I've seen
him with the officials he does not have
a technical yet as a football knocks
down his second three-pointer of the
game he now has 23 sole coupon that
Mick's paying out of hustle finish
there's honest so most of his damages
the seven debate is up to 11 points
there an average is fourteen point one
point one ye honest an Atlanta t20 no
just like the Bucks start of the game
crisp execution attack of the rib cities
dribble handoff with us communication
for New York that talk to each other
switch it it's game winners he made his
NBA debut against the Knicks in 2013 to
be around making it tough on him taking
him out of it he's getting points at the
bucket stands from Korea does take
something it's New York yeah it's
getting a little bit ugly now is the
score that easy I know he makes it look
easy a lot of times Platt
34 points in 19 minutes